- [Naz] You play a grown up Dan Torrance,
heavily influenced by his father,
so my first question to you is
what did you take from Danny
Lloyd and Jack Nicholson's
performances for your role?
- I mean I took a lot more
from Jack really because
I think when you're playing
the adult version of
a young child like that
there's only so much
you can get from their performance
and of course he was so brilliant
but he's like a blank canvas, wasn't he?
And Kubrick was able to use
his performance beautifully
but it was very sort of withheld
and I so I got much more
by watching Jack and I felt very much that
I know through experience
that we can't help but have
a lot of our fathers in
us as men so I listen
to a lot of Jack on set,
I listen to his interviews with him
or just to listen to
the cadence of his voice
'cause I feel we all sound like our dad.
Like if you met my dad now you would know,
you'd recognize my voice from his.
- [Naz] That you came from him.
- So I wanted to try and do
that with this so I tried to
sound a little bit like Jack
or at least have a flavor of
him in my voice when I'm playing Danny.
And then that sort of were,
and he's my dad so I just was
thinking of Jack Nicholson
being my dad and how cool
and strange that would be.
Then I left it because I feel
like that the homages and
the clever, the satisfying
elements I hope for the audience
that Mike Flanagan sort of
put into the movie where we
recognize scenes or moments
from "The Shining" in our film
it's best for me not to really
be thinking about because
I'm on the inside of it
and not that would be like
thinking on the outside.
- Right, did you talk to Jack Nicholson?
- I didn't, I must've met,
I know I seen him somewhere
and you know at awards or
something when I started off.
I know I've been in his company somewhere
but I've never met him or
spoken to him which is a shame.
- Well I thought you
did 'cause you nailed it
but I'm curious what is the
scariest part of "The Shining"
for you 'cause I know
you watched it as a teen
so it's so scary.
- I didn't really watch
it when it came out
'cause I just knew it had the reputation
of being the most
terrifying film ever made
so I was too sensitive to
watch that kind of thing
when I was a kid so I ended
up watching it in my twenties
probably for the first
time and I watched it alone
'cause I thought like well
if you're gonna do it,
you should do it properly,
I watched it at night alone.
And I think it's funny when
he meets and I can never
remember if it's Lloyd
or Floyd the bar man.
- [Naz] Lloyd.
- Lloyd, it's when he meets Lloyd.
Floyd wouldn't be so frightening would it?
- Floyd the bar, Floyd isn't frightening.
- Scary, Lloyd.
When he meets Lloyd in the
bar I think that's just when
suddenly he's there and Jack
has that conversation with him
that's probably,
that's when I started
hiding behind the sofa.
- Mike I'm so excited to
talk to you about this film.
I mean first off my thought
is how did you pull this off?
You had the unique job of making
a sequel to Kubrick Shining
and to King Shining so how
did you walk that tight rope?
With nothing but kind of
intense anxiety really
and I don't know if we pulled it off.
I won't know if we really pulled it off
until it's out there in the world.
But yeah I mean you're kind
of zeroing in on what has felt
like this intense ulcer
that's been eating away at me
for the last two years.
Yeah I grew up worshiping Stephen King.
I saw "The Shining" when
I was very, very young.
Way too young to see "The Shining".
And I've never had a film that
was kind of more formative
and influential on me and
I've never had another author
who I've idolized this much
so I don't know kind of how
we went about pulling it
all together short of it was
a thousand questions every day
that kind of just felt like
we were always on a tightrope
trying to kind of pull those
two sources together.
- Well congratulations
what an accomplishment
and I'm sure it was easier
'cause you are such a super fan
but now I'm curious,
what is the scariest part
of "The Shining" for you?
- Of the film or the book?
- [Naz] The film.
- The scariest scene of the movie for me,
it's the Grady twins the first time.
Not the first time you see
them which is in the game room
but the first time he
sees them after the hotel
is abandoned when he
comes around the corner
on the big wheel.
That knocked me out when I was a kid.
The image of them, their stillness,
the symmetry of it was terrifying.
I think as I've gotten older
the scariest scene of the film
to me is the conversation
in the bathroom between
Jack Torrance and Delbert Grady.
- [Naz] So terrifying.
- Yeah the insidious kind of
casual suggestion of the scene
to me is just chilling.
And you killed it recreating it so good.
I have to ask because
our fans are huge fans of
"Haunting of Hill House".
I wanted to ask you about
"Blind Man" or what can you tell
me about it and how will it be different
from the first series?
Well you know it's all
based on the writing of
Henry James this time
which is really cool and--
- [Naz] The Turn of the Screw.
- The Turn of the Screw yes,
which has been adapted actually
so many times that it's
kind of impossible to find
a straight adaptation that
hasn't already been done
and done perfectly I think in the case of
Jack Clayton's "The Innocence".
You know so the really
cool surprise for everybody
with this season I think
is that we're not limited
just to that source.
We have access to all of
Henry James's ghost stories
that haven't been adapted to death
and so it really is kind of turning
into a very cool greatest
hits album of all of the
Henry James ghost stories
and "Turn of the Screw"
is just kind of the most famous of them.
There's a bunch of other
really wonderful material
that's all kind of being
braided together for this
that I think is really cool.
- Well I can't wait to
see what you do with that.
I love your aesthetic so much.
Especially in this movie
too and I feel like color
is very important to you
so how do you develop
your aesthetic and what
does the color blue mean
in this film 'cause it's everywhere.
- The cool blues have been only increasing
kind of in my work over
the last few years.
I just love, I love the
way it looks is really,
the not nearly as intellectual answers
that you want I'm sure
but color is critical.
I think Stanley Kubrick
understood that in a way
that was so far ahead of his time.
For me and for Michael
Fimognari who's been my DP now
since "Oculus" kind of
since from the beginning,
we're always trying to find
the palette that not only kind
of starts to connect that
connects kind of all of the work
we do together into the same family.
But that is also kind of
pulling away the warmth from the
story visually and a story
like this in particular,
when we used colors on the
warm side of the spectrum,
when we did get into our
reds and our oranges,
I wanted it to land with a
lot of impact and that meant
that when we're out in
the world before that,
pulling that warmth out
letting everything get kind of
cobalt get really kind of
cold I thought that could be
a really wonderful way to approach it.
- Congratulations on the film, Rebecca.
I was so excited to see you
in it and when I was reading
about the fact that you hate scary stuff
and then thought about the role
that you played in this film, I was like,
what was the biggest challenge for you?
- Cognitive therapy.
That's what it is, you know.
Challenge your fear.
It is very different, I was
gonna say, it's very different
shooting something and being
a part of something than
watching it because I am in
utter control of what I'm doing
and I know the outcome.
The idea of sitting in a
cinema and things jump out
is just not fun.
I just get really
nervous talking about it.
I hate it so much.
- Well here's the thing.
There's this scene, there's
a murder scene in this film
that is the most traumatizing
that another actor plays
and I'm sure that was, I
mean what was that like?
- Pretty intense.
Unexpected.
I didn't think I would have
such a acute reaction to the
acting to the point that I
actually needed to shape up
because I would've ruined the scene.
And then I broke down a little
bit after and turned around
and script supervisor
was in floods of tears.
One of the actors of my
clan, it doesn't matter who,
had a memory from something
that had happened.
So that person walked off.
I mean it was, it was crazy.
And then we all had pizza.
That's kind of how it works.
- Typical Friday night.
- And then we have pizza.
But the person who was
creating this emotion sat up
when it was done and literally went,
"Can I have something to drink
thanks I'm great thanks."
We were going "What?"
- Such an incredible
performance for me that was the
scariest part of the film but
I'm curious to know what is
the scariest part of "The
Shining" the film for you?
- Oh gosh, yeah but there so many bits
and I always wanna be smart.
I get very affected by the
sound effects of things.
Obviously when things jump out
but that's the simple answer.
For me I find the cycling, the tricycle,
of him going down the corridor
and we know what's to expect
and we don't want him to
stop by the bloody door
and yet he does it.
But it's the carpet to the wood.
- Yes it's like a heartbeat that goes
with a heartbeat soundtrack.
- And you know that Mike,
actually as the geek he is,
he built the, they built
a grown up version of it
and we all got to do it.
We literally queued up and we
did the whole cycle bicycle
on the carpet.
- I read about that he made a big wheel.
What was that like riding around?
- Incredible.
And then the competition
was on who did the quickest.
Obviously.
- You?
- Yes sure.
No, I mean Mike.
With pizza in one hand.
- That's so funny.
Our fans over at Rotten
Tomatoes are huge fans of "Dune"
and I know you just wrapped on that film
and I was hoping you could
tell me about your role.
- I play the mother, the
protector, the Bene Gesserit.
It's an incredible role.
What is wonderful is Denis
Villeneuve he is together with
the writers creating something
that works today because the
book that was written by
Frank Herbert back in the day
wasn't as metooish as we would've hoped.
We have learned better.
So I'm kind of a part of a
change for this character.
An empowerment of her.
But yes it was lots to learn
and incredible actors
to work with, action.
- Your chemistry with Ewan
McGregor is so good in the movie
so I wanna know what was
it like working with him
and I wanna know about the
first time you guys met.
- Well the first time we met was actually
in the reading room in audition.
I was extremely nervous.
I was twitching all over the place.
I actually told him when we
were shooting like a true knot
scene I told him that I was
twitching all over the place.
I don't know if he saw it
but my leg was doing this.
That was the first time we
met and I think it was kind of
funny I was acting weird, twitching.
But we had a lot of fun reading.
I think because we grew a
friendship off set we were able to
connect Abra and Dan better
and I'm really happy I got to
work with him.
He's such an amazing person.
- What was he like working
with on set when you guys
were in character?
- Fascinating, I mean it's
so cool just to watch him
switch from Mr. Ewan to Dan yeah.
- What were like the big key differences?
- Well one, the accent.
Two, Dan's more dark than Mr. Ewan
and I thought that was kind of cool.
That was wacky but it was cool.
- I like that he, you know
this was your first movie and
Ewan's an actor that's
been around for a while
and Abra has Uncle Dan as a
mentor so I felt like that
there was some sort of similar dynamic.
- Oh yeah I see Mr. Ewan
a lot as my mentoree
and I think that's how we
relate to Dan and Abra.
- Nice, well you killed it.
- Thank you.
- I read that your Mom took
you to see "The Shining".
- Yes, my Mom and Dad.
- So what was that like and
what is the scariest part of
"The Shining" for you?
- Well, the spirits.
The spirits are horrible.
And also the title cards
I found that so funny.
I was in the movie theater.
The sound is surrounding you.
You're getting weird vibes and then bam!
There's Tuesday!
That scared me.
I don't know why but it did.
- That's so funny that's
interesting though a title card.
What was the scariest
part of filming on set?
'Cause you do some real
serious stuff in this film.
- It was mostly fun.
But I think the scariest
ones were with the
spirits in The Overlook.
With Miss Massey when she
had all her teeth done
and her full suit,
I really wanted to get sick.
It was gross.
But as a peace treaty,
I won't scare you if you don't scare me.
We did the macarena to kind of
just smother my extreme fear.
- What?
Like in costume?
- Yeah I walked in during
rehearsal and I went "Aaaah!"
So in between takes we did the macarena.
- To like not freak you out?
- Yes.
- Who's idea was that?
Was that Mike's idea.
- Mine.
- Oh that's really cool.
What was it like working
with Mike Flanagan?
He's amazing.
The world does not deserve Mike Flanagan.
He's absolutely, he's so talented
and he gave us so much creative freedom.
I'm so grateful for that
because not a lot of directors
give you that and he actually
called me and Mr. Ewan
in for a meeting about our characters
and we talked about them
and he wanted to know
if we wanted to add anything
which was super sweet.
- And what did you say?
Did you add anything Abra?
- I really just asked him
about Abra's character
and what he kind of saw for her.
(sinister music)
- [Man] But the things that lived there.
- [Both Twins] Hello Danny.
- [Man] They come back.
(sinister music)